this is your skull this is your skull
after a collision without a helmet hi my
name is Aneesa Ramirez welcome to
science explained and a special edition
on the football helmet now there's been
a lot of news about football and
injuries and I've been very curious so I
wanted to share what I learned with you
in terms of how these things protect
players from getting hurt let's look at
a football helmet together hey here's
one first off the engineering behind
this helmet is incredible when you think
about a helmet think 1 2 3 there are 3
parts there's the hard shell the rigid
foam and then there's a softer foam that
sometimes inside the hard shell protects
the player from rough surfaces and
cleats and friction it also helps to
distribute the force during impact the
foam inside is used to absorb and also
to distribute the force and there's also
a softer phone not in this one but the
softer foam which also helps to absorb
the force and also prevents the players
from being uncomfortable so this helmet
is essentially bubble wrap for your
brain now imagine that this egg is your
head the yolk inside is your brain
bubble wrap can do a very good job of
protecting the yolk from cracking in
fact I have an egg inside of all this
and I can drop it and it doesn't crack
helmets prevent skulls from fracturing
what they're not designed to do is
prevent yolks or your brain from
sloshing around
that's a concussion so we need new
science we need new materials inside of
the helmet we might even need a new
helmet it's going to take some time to
develop the solution to prevent
concussions and to keep players away
from harm all of us engineers players
owners officials and fans like yourself
we're all going to have to put our heads
together figuratively of course I'm
Anissa Ramirez thank you for joining me
at science explained and I hope that
you'll come back
for another edition